i mean i think there are parts of it
that uh
will potentially go some way but
ultimately it's very thin on the ground
um and tomorrow next month
next year if this strategy is put in
place
i have to say i still think that street
harassment will
be rife uh the cases of it being
successfully managed by um our criminal
justice system will be exactly the same
as they are today
and nothing will have changed in
uh how rape cases are currently
proceeding through the criminal justice
system
so i have to say i find it very
disappointing
i mean there is to be a new national
policing lead a senior officer out there
to ensure
best practice and improve police
responses to
violence against women and girls that
that seems like progress
i mean that's progress in the category
of violence against women and girls but
of course we have a senior police
officer who does that in domestic abuse
we have a senior police officer who does
that in rape and sexual violence
those areas where cases are rising and
charging and conviction is falling um
and
so you know i really want to see that
position properly resourced
like i want to see those other senior
police officers properly resourced so
that they were actually able to do their
jobs
but there's absolutely nothing in the
strategy that does that
so whilst that is progress in the
broader term of violence against women
and girls
i'm not entirely sure what this person
will be able to do how they'll be the
silver bullet where
the commissioner for in sexual violence
rape cases child sexual exploitation and
domestic abuse all have their own police
lead
and we're still failing on all of those
areas
i mean many of the um complaints and
testimonies
came in the wake as i was just saying of
this horrendous case of sarah everard
and many of those testimonies spoke
about the lack of confidence
in the police and the response of the
police and i guess a senior police
officer
you know may try to change that
i mean i absolutely hope so and i think
that your average police officer
cares about this and i work with
brilliant police officers in this space
all the time
but they simply don't have the resources
to be dealing
with uh the number of cases that are in
front of them about
domestic abuse let alone um street
harassment and that's because they
haven't been properly resourced and
violence against women and girls has
never been made
the priority um by the government in
order to make sure that the police are
properly
resourced to be able to do that i mean
are you calling for new laws
you mentioned street harassment a
specific law on
street harassment because of course
there are already laws
i mean it may be just that and they're
not being used effectively
well currently there is a um a variety
of different laws that
you might reach the threshold of or you
you might not
um that when they said they're not being
used successfully they're not being used
at all when i speak as somebody who has
taken harassment cases
myself and often what i'm told is oh you
know you might be able to get it in on
this one particular law about online
harassment or you might be able to get
it
on uh you know whether you feel alarm
and distressed
and actually what tends to happen is
that and i'm a public figure
so imagine i'm getting a considerably
better service
that it's far too confusing and the
average police officer sat in front of
me doesn't actually know
um and it needs to just be a very very
clear
public law harassment charge
that can be taken whether that's taken
as a civil issue like they have
trialled in front they have a law in
france which is called like
arriba sexist like horrible sexists um
god loves the french language um where
there's a ticketing system that goes on
when people are seen to be harassing and
being misogynistic in the street
now that nothing in this proposal is
proposing that it's just saying oh we're
going to try and use our current laws
better well anyone who's ever brought a
harassment charge
will just know how exactly how well that
goes yeah but there are i mean the laws
do exist section 5 of the public order
act it covers
you know offensive offences involving
abusive language gestures behavior with
intent to cause
another harassment alarm and distress so
it
you know my point is the laws are there
it's just maybe
that they're not being used or not being
used effectively
well if that is the case what i think
needs to happen is there to be a
specific
law specifically for that that the
police can understand
that the public how many people in my
constituency think you know that section
of the
section five of the public order act and
know that that's what they've got to ask
for
the point is is it's too confusing at
the moment
and it needs to and yeah okay the
government can say all the laws already
exist
watch in the next 10 years how that
makes absolutely no difference
and i suppose the kind of baseline here
is that what needs to change is
behavioral
you know behavioral change of of
some men how does how i mean this talks
about it this strategy talks about that
what
but how do you bring that about well you
need proper education
from a very early age about gendered
attitudes misogyny consent
and that needs to be happening in
schools teachers need to be properly
trained in how to do it
um as we've seen from recent ofsted
reports that say
it's institutionalized sexual harassment
happening in in schools
that we teachers need training but they
also need the resources to bring in
specialist agencies and what is
completely lacking from this strategy
is a single penny piece of extra money
for the specialist agencies
who are going to be expected to deliver
this strategy and it's
that's simply the problem so we need we
need public
awareness raising campaigns and all of
that at every stage in life
to tell people what they should and
shouldn't be saying because for too many
women they are on the the wrong end of
that and and lots of men tell me that
they don't know what to do when they see
this sort of thing happening so we need
proper robust education from a very
early age and
long into life yeah okay look we've got
30 seconds left
what what is there not in this strategy
that you would have liked to have seen
in the strategy
well um for a start off there is
absolutely nothing about adult sexual
exploitation there's not a single
mention of it apart from
one thing that says online they'll try
and make porn companies be better on
extra exploitation voluntarily
so there is nothing for victims who are
being
you know very very vulnerable people
with suffering with terrible
issues who are being sexually exploited
as adults not one single thing